[Applaudissements]
cette question s'adresse à madame la
ministre berérangerre Couillard ministre
de l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes 52 jours 52 jours déjà se sont
écoulés depuis ce samedi sanglant au
cours duquel s'est ouvert un gouffre
abissal dans lequel a été aspiré notre
humanité un gouffre fait de sang de
torture de mutilations et de larmes une
violence absolue commise au nom de Allah
Akbar par des monstres armés de couteau
et dépourvus de cœur le octobre dernier
des terroristes islamistes du Hamas
bibronné à la haine des Juifs ont
pénétré le territoire souverain d'Israël
pour commettre de telles atrocités qu'un
esprit humain du mal à le concevoir si
cette passion exterminatrice a visé
indifféremment des hommes des personnes
âgées des adolescents des enfants des
bébés elle a aussi ciblé spécifiquement
des femmes les associations féministes
adeptes des Mitou de l'écriture
inclusive et des hones croix au aurait
dû condamner avec force les viols
acharnés les femmes enceintes et ventré
la nudité carbonisée les adolescentes
exhibé comme autant de macabres
trophées il n'en a pourtant rien été les
nouvelles féministes intersectionnelles
se sont tues elles ont balayé d'un
revers de main les victimes de ces
abominations sous le prétexte évident de
leur origine israélienne et juive elles
ont effacé la douleur de ces femmes
suppliciées parfois même en idolâtrant
la violence de leur bourreaux devenu
soudainement des résistants se fait ce
féminisme à géométrie variable pour
lequel les origines importent davantage
que les faits criminels a choisi
d'exclure samedi dernier l'accès à la
marche contre les violences faites aux
femmes aux manifestantes venu rappeler
la mémoire des femmes victimes du
pogrome du 7 octobre parfois encore
retenu comme otage dans les tunnels du
ramas quand on combat les violences fait
aux femmes on les combat partout et tout
le temps Madame la Ministre que
comptez-vous faire pour garantir que les
subventions de l'État ne des
associations la parole est à Madame
berangard ministre en charge de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et de la lutte contre les
discrimination
merci beaucoup mes chers collègues
madame la ministre merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée yadan ce qui
s'est passé en Israël est
abominable des femmes ont été violé ont
été mutilé elles ont été torturées le
viol est une arme de guerre laissant de
nombreuses femmes et filles
psychologiquement
traumatisé souvent la violence sexuelle
n'est pas simplement perpétrée par des
soldat Solitair mais s'apparente à une
tactique de guerre
délibérée la violence sexuelle déplace
terrorise détruit des individus des
familles et des communautés entières
atteignant des niveaux de cruauté
inimaginables à l'égard de femmes de
tout âge ces horreurs qu'elles aient eu
lieu en Israël où de nombreux cas de
viol ont été rapporté le 7 octobre
dernier en Ukraine au Soudan ou dans le
reste du monde je les ai condamnés et je
les condamne ici
fermement vous évoquez madame la députée
tout particulièrement la manifestation
du 25 novembre pourquoi a-t-elle été
créée pour lutter contre les violences
faites aux femmes c'est un combat qui
est universel et je déénonce de nouveau
de nouveau ici l'instrumentalisation qui
en a été faite madame la députée on ne
trie pas les violences en fonction des
conflits des individus ou des
nationalités je m'oppose fermement à
toute forme de récupération c'est là que
la diplomatie féministe a tout son
importance tous les conflits rappellent
la nécessité de la mise en œuvre de
l'agenda femmes paix sécurité il
reconnaît que la participation des
femmes au mécanism des résolutions des
crises et de stabilisation est
indispensable et un impact positif sur
la paix 104 étatsmembres des Nations
Unies ont déjà adopté ce plan d'action
au niveau national madame la députée
vous me posez plus particulièrement la
question des subventions aux
associations sachez que les projets
soumis à ces subventions doivent
s'inscrire pleinement dans les
orientations de mon ministère et je suis
évidemment extrêmement vigilante à ce
que les associations partagent nos
valeurs universelles et donc elles
seront soutenues que si elles partagent
ses valeurs universelles merci beaucoup
madame la
ministre